every few months a team from the
Australian government science agency
csiro and the Australian Bureau of
meteorology will bottle up air from here
at the northern tip of Tasmania and send
it off to be archived a few days ago
back on the Australian mainland in a
suburb of Melbourne I interviewed one of
the team at the air archive to explain
how and why the first tank was taken on
the 26th of April 1978. all up we have
close to 200 tanks spanning almost 50
years the pressure they get to is around
about 900 PSI they're 34 liter tanks
which means they hold around 2 000
liters of air once they're completely
full this price Canada Cape Grimm has
the cleanest air in the world when the
wind's blowing from the south west when
that air has traveled thousands of
kilometers across the Southern Ocean
without touching land so that is a
monitoring station testing the levels of
dozens of gases and chemicals in the
atmosphere when we say clean air or
Baseline air we mean that it has not had
recent contact with land or pollution
sources and we know that it's very
representative of the mid-latitudes of
the Southern Hemisphere background air
and most of the sources of the major
greenhouse gases are in the northern
hemisphere because that's where the
major population centers are it takes
about a year to do the inter hemispheric
transport going across the equator is
much much slower than the mixing within
a hemisphere itself we wait until the
wind is coming from the southwest
Direction and normally we wait several
hours today the wind is not blowing in
the right direction it's blowing in from
the cities in Tasmania and the
Australian Mainland but the team here
are going to do a practice fill of an
archived cylinder so they can show you
what would happen and it's a really
technical operation that has to avoid
contamination these cylinders are filled
cryogenically under vacuum when they're
put into the liquid nitrogen the air
naturally will be sucked into the tanks
over two to three hour period as any gas
cools down it compresses so initially
via rushes in to fill the vacuum but
then it hits liquid nitrogen chilled
stainless steel so it cools and
compresses and more air rushes in which
cools and compresses and so on and so on
and so on it's a really clever way to
fill a pressurized canister without
pumps we then let it heat up or warm up
and then we blast whatever water is in
there out there is water in the tanks
because there's water in the atmosphere
and we don't do any drying we don't want
to use pumps or any particular drying
agent or method as this can potentially
contaminate in the tanks so I have an
obvious question how do they know that
the air and the archive tanks doesn't
change over time through some chemical
reaction or osmosis through a faulty
valve or microbe contamination we take
measurements of the archive regularly
maybe once a year we'll take a sniff out
of each of the cylinders so to speak to
ensure Trace gases are not drifting or
changing there is a little bit of
moisture and water in there and there
has been concerns where the microbes
might be changing the composition for
some Trace gases but for what we've
discovered so far that's not really the
case so they've got an archive what do
they do with well let's say someone
discovers that actually there's a
greenhouse gas or some other contaminant
that we should have been testing for for
the last 50 years or so the researchers
can go to the archive pull samples from
the tanks and use modern equipment to
test old Air remember CFCs they've been
testing for those on site here for years
but it turns out The Replacements also
cause problems after the CFCs were the
interim Replacements hcfcs and then the
replacements for those hfcs it's only
recently we've had the technology to be
able to measure those to build up a
history back in time to 1978 that would
not be possible without the archive some
of the measurements we do take just 20
or 30 mils of air we can actually take
measurements down to parts per trillion
there was one more thing that Paul
showed me back at Melbourne the first
tank taken here in 1978 it's not the
oldest one in the archive several years
ago we did a media story and we started
to get inquiries from the public saying
we've got older air than you and it
turns out there was a lot of people out
there with old scuba tanks sitting in
their garages and most scuba divers kept
a diary of when they dived when and
where the tank was filled so people
started to donate their scuba tanks so
we now have air back to 1956. for some
Trace gases that we're interested in are
perfectly fine to take the measurements
all right I am
what makes the microphone held up thank
you so much no worries